we simulated the ultimate NBA Christmas
Showdown with Shaq and Kobe taking on
Santa Claus and the Grinch look Shaq and
Kobe might be the greatest Duo ever but
St Nick always delivers in December and
the Grinch is mean as hell Shaq was
dominant early treating Santa like a
stocking stuffer in the paint check out
these blocks by Shaq and the dive right
into the snow you love to see that
Hustle but Santa was flying like Rudolph
on Christmas Eve and the Grinch was
thrown down absolute nasty posters all
game the game was close for a while but
Shaq and Kobe eventually took a eight 13
lead Santa tried to spark a comeback
hitting a three from the North Pole but
it was too little too late Kobe said
Merry Christmas to all and all a good
night and hit the Grinch with a
hesitation crossover and a floater for a
21 to 18 win